deshalb 500 gramm und ich habe das mal
an einem abend so in zehn minuten
weggehauen einfach weil's so lecker
geschmeckt hat da wundert ihr euch
wahrscheinlich immer warum ich nicht
dick bin ich weiß auch nicht was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut mir auch danke komischerweise
immer in essen - immer noch was an die
begrüßung ergänzt
heute wird es zeit für einen nächsten
teil meines format ich teste alle
produkte von einer sorte diesem
supermarkt gibt hier habe ich mir das
nochmal netzpartner nicht este alle
sorten aus dem supermarkt
das ist glaube ich leicht da bis jetzt
hatten wir fünf minuten terrinen und wir
hatten letztes mal pringles und heute
steht habe ich in den kommentaren
gelesen schokopudding sagen aber ich bin
selber drauf gekommen ich weiß jetzt gar
nicht mehr auf jeden fall war ich eben
einkaufen und habe einfach alles öko
politik auf dies da gab die verkäuferin
dachte aus warum kopf dieser typ so
viele verschiedene sorten zucker wurde
ihm genau ich zeige euch die mal kurz
nützlich im kühlschrank 123 47 pendant
also ich habe wirklich alle gekauft mehr
gab es nicht
ich dachte erst so ok schokopudding
sport da findest du bestimmt zwanzig
dreißig verschiedene aber war halt nicht
so zumindest in dem laden ruhig war
könnte ja vielleicht ich muss sagen
früher habe ich sehr sehr auf diesen
hergerissen von nein also nein nicht von
dieser marke sondern von einer anderen
marke
der sei aber vom design her gleich aus
so dieser typische schoko sahne joghurt
also dass sie sind allerdings entweder
mit oder ohne sahne die probieren wir
heute verteilen wie der punkte von eins
bis zehn und haben
ende den besten schokopudding das ganze
wird es in zukunft auch mit anderen
produkt geben eure wunschprodukte in die
kommentare
ich freue mich drauf gibt den
kommentaren die euch gefallen daumen
nach oben dann sehe ich das ja abonniert
den kanal jeden tag 19 uhr neues video
ich muss jetzt erst mal kurz zu machen
ich weiß ich hab ich schon erwähnt habe
jeder joghurt bekommt eine punktzahl von
eins bis zehn
die werden am ende sortiert dann haben
wir hier den besten hier den
schlechtesten und ich muss sagen ich
habe von diesen ganzen joghurts bis
jetzt noch gar kein probiert außerdem
hier unten a und d obwohl nicht mal den
ihr das ist dieser allerdings habe ich
nur vanille edition mal getestet wir
fangen einfach mal mit dem wir oben an
und zwar ist es was haben wir euch
sehgal das ist gar nicht 100 prozent öko
sondern nutzt schoko nicht aber lecker
probiere ich mal schmeckt aber schon
seiner schokolade alter mega gut
ich glaube bei dem video wird mir
eigentlich alles gut schmecken und
danach zu mir wahrscheinlich schlecht
leute richtig guter joghurt ich fange
hier direkt mal an mit acht punkten acht
punkte es gut also hat mich auf jeden
fall schon mal was also macht weiter mit
dem angebot also allen gut joghurts auch
von erman ehrenmal im märz ist ja mal
einen spaß erlaubt und aus diesem
ermahnen gemacht finde ich lustig ich
dachte immer einen gurt wer eine eigene
marke jetzt stehe ich gerade das dass er
mann gesehen habe ich auf jeden fall
noch nie gesehen ich kenne nur von
dieser marken so diese himbeer joghurt
erdbeer joghurt schokolade
ich bin mal gespannt ob ihr das auch
können der rest wirkt auf alles was ich
bis jetzt von denen man im westen ist
aber nahe dass leute das sieht ja schon
so geil aus der hier lag preislich auf
jeden fall unter einem euro der hier
drüber ist ja auch mehr drin deswegen
ist das in ordnung
hugo leute gebt euch dass man schaut mal
hier ein alter gut mir fällt auf dass
hier ist natürlich erst ein klassischer
joghurt wobei die hat mich was ist denn
der unterschied zwischen dem joghurt und
im pudding für mich sagt eigentlich dass
gleichfalls ihr da eine genaue
definition habt lasst es mich gerne in
den kommentaren wissen das schmeckt mir
allerdings ein bisschen zu wenig nach
schokolade das ist eigentlich geeignet
schokolade
hast du das problem muss ich leider so
überzeugt mir nicht deswegen gibt es
hier auch nur sechs von zehn punkten
machen mit dem land liebe joghurt weiter
landliebe das kind auch direkt immer
richtig gesunde war schild vonlanthen
frisch gesund und dann gibt's halt auch
so gut ich glaube jetzt nicht dass der
so gesund ist aber nicht auf jeden fall
ich muss ja sagen wir für euch den es am
krassesten so vom aussehen her ist ja
auf jeden fall dieser rinne gebt euch
den mal ich mach mal kurz vor dem ko
system know how
hier und da noch schön wie die sahne
creme oben schokopudding okay gut
weitergeht
er schmeckt extrem kastner schokolade
und schon ein bisschen zu künstlich
irgendwie ich weiß auch nicht leistung
bitterer neben geschmack bei ich hätte
gedacht vielleicht ist es so zart
bitterschokolade aber steht ganz normale
schokolade drauf keine ahnung überzeugt
mich auch nicht ganz deswegen gibt es
auch hier von mir 614 punkten
das ist eine super note kommen jetzt
meiner lieblings marke nein ich muss
sagen früher zum beispiel ich habe diese
sahne auf diesen joghurts gehasst
ich habe nie verstanden warum das sage
drauf ist wunderbar ich überhaupt kein
schamgefühl
heutzutage muss ich sagen es schmeckt
eigentlich gut naja wir wollen ja die
schokolade haben überzeugt mich gar
nicht werfen muss ich sagen das hier war
mit 35 cent der günstigste joghurt von
allen und für 35 cent erwartet man jetzt
ja auch nicht die welt aber trotzdem
muss ich sagen immer wenn ich was von
der marke nein
probiere oder mich dazu entscheide okay
das ist jetzt günstiger nimmst du mal
gas und nicht das originalprodukt dann
ist das immer gut und die qualität ist
eigentlich genau wie beim original hier
muss ich jetzt sagen auch wenn ich den
schoko joghurt schokopudding was auch
immer den ich früher immer gegessen habe
er hat genauso aufgebaut warum genauso
aussah nicht gefunden habt vermutlich
weil dieses produkt dem verdrängt hat
einfach deutlich günstiger es schmeckt
allerdings meiner meinung nach nicht mal
annähernd so gut auch ein extrem
künstlich deswegen jetzt familie lieb
gemeinte vier von zehn punkte wer
allerdings nicht sorry wenn ich im
internet ein foto von diesem pudding
joghurt dem durcheinander doch mal gute
idee wir müssen jetzt einmal das wort
joghurt und pudding und machen ihr ding
weil dann haben wir halt so eine
verallgemeinerung wenn ich dieses ding
im internet findet blende ich euch denn
hier mal ein also den wir nicht früher
gegessen habe und jetzt kommen wir zu
der nicht mal die hälfte kommen wir als
nächstes zum pudding also ich glaube da
ist eine holländische marke und die
vanille variante
davon ist schon heftigkeit also also da
sitze ich damals war abends mir so einen
löffel nimmt noch ein
und da sind halt anders noch größer
fasste deshalb 500 gramm und ich habe
das mal ein eimer mit seinen zehn
minuten weggehauen einfach weil's so
lecker geschmeckt hat da wundert ihr
euch wahrscheinlich immer warum ich
nicht dick bin ich war nicht okay jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt wie das ist schon
heftig urteil
wir können dann schon wieder wer ich bin
ich mit direkten hat musste sich auf 10
von 10 besser geht nicht
ich wollte sie nicht töten von zehn
womöglich noch nie gemacht das ist
wirklich im schokoladenpudding next
level up nico hier das sind sogar die
500 gramm habe ich denn dann 750 gramm
gefuttert davon ich weiß nicht mehr hat
ein eur 69 gekostet finde ich aber
preislich okay man hat ja auch eine
große menge also elf von 10 besser geht
nicht ganz kampagne ding testen war den
schoko pudding von möwen klick ja sieht
irgendwie nach ziemlich wenig aus dem
kokon laden für finden gut was wir bis
jetzt auf jeden fall aufgefallen ist
jeder jedem schmeckt anders nach
schokolade also die strecke natürlich
alle nach schokolade der eine mehr der
andere weniger aber irgendwie immer
anders der jetzt nice kriegt von mir
acht von zehn punkte dh du kommst hier
genau da nochmal zum nächsten bin ich
sehr gespannt drauf schokoladenpudding
südost aber okay das war glaube ich der
teuerste wobei letzterer auch 169
gekostet 375 gramm leute auch nur
verdammt gut
richtig lecker schneller wieder zu
machen sonst hätte ich davon zu viel
kriegt neun von zehn punkte hat mich
jetzt nicht zu hundert prozent überzeugt
aber es war schon ganz nah dran
guter geschmack schmeckt nicht künstlich
kann ich im film und wie gesagt da habe
ich wohl noch nie gesehen sind
schokoladenpudding ich mache meinen
eigenen kollegen alex wiesler ding so
langsam merke ich dass das ganze gerade
nicht gut ist ich habe mal den nächsten
schokoladen guck mal da sind so
sahnetörtchen obendrauf die weltraum
sind das auch das sind auch keine 150
das sind maximal 50 guck mal wie klein
das ist weckt aber dennoch gut ich will
ja von jetzt noch kommen einmal auch
hier
er schmeckt so ein bisschen wie diese
hier den ich halt früher gegessen habe
bei der schokolade ja deswegen gibt es
von mir auch hier neun von zehn punkte
kommen wir zum nächsten shooting schoko
ring mit soße vanillegeschmack ich meine
den habe ich mir irgendwann mal
mitgenommen einfach weil ich denn so
weiß fand das hat mich so andere lächeln
weil es so lecker aussieht aber dann hat
mich überzeugt deswegen bin ich mal
gespannt wie möglich auf jeden fall
direkt eine sehr feste konsistenz
schnell im abba kollegen ströer nach
stiften alter wenn man sowas braucht ja
nie weiter ist und genau das war das das
hatte ich noch im hinterkopf irgendwann
hat es dann schon mal nach warte man
muss man ihn auf den kopf stellen könnte
mir dort auf steht zumindest hier sind
ja an sich geht es ja hier um die
schokolade deswegen nicht gut 25 cent
pro liter und das ist der verlierer
heute und dann aber zum schluss den
nächsten von müll und schokopudding mit
sahne ab und der ist jetzt so hat dunkle
schokolade sieht man auch schmeckt ein
bisschen bitterer allerdings nicht so
bitter wie der den wm hatten von
landliebe bis auf goal.com boom boom
kommt hier zwischen löcher aber ohne
spaß wenn die dänen die noch nicht
probiert habt war heftig also das hat
mich voll überzeugt habe natur
zusammengefasst zwei punkte 4 punkte 6
punkte 6 punkte 788 8 9 11 glaube ich
irgendwie so also war dann ein
spannendes video
jetzt weiß ich welche schule vorlegen
ich das nächste mal auf jeden fall
mitnehmen und zwar den hier
obwohl ich wirklich selten so was ist
eure aufgabe ist jetzt erstmal die
glocke zu aktivieren
den kanal zu abonnieren und mini
kommentare weitere produkte schreiben
von denen ich mal alle sorten testen
soll ich bin gespannt auf die letzten
beiden parks ab die schon anleihen sind
und wir sehen uns dann morgen
immer wieder gibt es ein neues video
morgen kommt ein wirklich cooles video
mit einem sehr coolen gast freut euch
drauf haut rein